rogue one a Star Wars story is now
assuming through theaters and if you got
to experience it hopefully you enjoyed
the film as I did if you saw my original
review you know that I liked the movie I
didn't love it I had problems with it
but overall the positives definitely
outweigh the negatives I still have
issues with the movie and in hard
internet society nowadays it's like what
you didn't love it what you didn't hate
it well then what are you are you just
some weird alien thing that you've just
kind of you liked a movie but tonight I
saw the film again and I took a lot of
notes very messy notes because it was a
dark Theater and I was doing my best but
this is going to be a spoiler filled
review so if you have not yet seen row 1
I'm about to talk about the entire film
in depth so if you don't want to be
spoiled I've just warned you let's do
this thing
so first let's talk about a few things I
didn't talk about in my initial review
that of Michael Giacchino's score it
does kind of sound a little rushed it's
not bad by any means it's not
necessarily something that I don't like
I just am such a fan of him I've been
listening to his scores ever since his
first score for Call of Duty that's how
far back I go as a fan of Michael
Giacchino so I watched this film and I
expect a little more but at the same
time I know they'd only had four weeks
to compose for this film because
Alexandre des plot got booted and he
came in there and he did his best I
think for such a small minut time in
fact it's incredible the amount of
effort that is put into this score for
only having a month to do it and it's
that score that opens this film with a
boom there's no crawl it just starts and
it's exciting right off the bat Mads
Mikkelsen one of my favorite actors as
Galen or so is trying to protect his
family from chronic portrayed by Ben
Mendelsohn who in my review I said was
good in this movie suitably over-the-top
very fun he has that you know fire
firing ready you rebel scum you know he
works in this universe he doesn't get to
do all that much in the film though he
kind of just storms around and goes this
has my creation I created a desktop
cartoon talking and when Jin is left
behind she's found by Saul Guerrero
by Forest Whitaker and something that
kind of bugged me that was such a small
little nitpicky moment that I don't
really understand is that she seems to
have a stormtrooper doll because one of
the death troopers finds a stormtrooper
doll and he thinks that maybe she's
around this area I don't get why she
would have a stormtrooper doll it looks
like a stormtrooper to me I've seen the
movie twice now because her dad seems to
hate the empire in the first 20 minutes
or so we go to so many different planets
this is the first time we've ever
actually seen the name of the planet
telling us where we are come up on
screen this film underwent extensive
reshoots as I said in my original review
and as most of you probably know and
there have been a lot of reports about
Tony Gilroy and how much he was involved
in how much he got paid the fact that he
perhaps changed the entire ending and
helped stitch that together and there
are moments this movie that really do
feel a little conflicted with itself
because it starts off and it's trying to
introduce a lot of different characters
which is great in a Star Wars movie you
want to go all over the galaxy you want
to feel like it's this big expansive
thing but from a storytelling
perspective I felt kind of like a
pinball in a pinball machine just being
knocked all over the place really fast
so after saw Guerrera rescues Jin we get
the title card rogue one and then it
just kind of cuts into the future really
far she's an adult now she's in prison
she's clearly not the greatest person
dealing with a lot of problems diego
luna is also not the greatest person
because although he appears to be a
rebel IE a good guy he shoots a guy in
the back after he gets the information
he needs and kind of just leaves and
this ties into the fact that this film
explores the side of the rebellion that
isn't necessarily squeaky clean these
guys can get dirty these guys can do
things that they don't feel happy about
and i like that there isn't really much
else given to diego luna's character i
mentioned in my spoiler free review that
he has one outbursts where we learn a
little bit about him and that is that he
says I've been doing this since I was
six years old I've been in this since I
was six and that's about the extent of
what we learned about him he says that
you're not the only one gen who's lost
everything some of us just decided to do
something about it that's a really good
line but overall that's about
in regards to learning about his
character except for when people
introduce him and that's actually a
thing that happens a lot in this movie a
character will come on screen and
introduce themselves and say who they
are and what they are or someone else
will introduce a character and say who
they are and what they've done and that
happens a lot with Jin people say those
is Jin here's your list of all these
offenses you've made the same thing with
Jago here's Captain Kassian and this is
what he does even k2s oh the first thing
he says is like hello I'm a reprogrammed
Imperial droid my specialty is strategic
analysis and I'm like okay that's cool I
mean I get that you need to know these
things in the original Star Wars films
to c-3po I'd be like I'm a protocol
droid I'm fluent in six million forms of
communication and that's fine I expect
movies to have some exposition I know
that that's a requirement and sometimes
it's inescapable but in this film I want
a little more especially in a Star Wars
movie I want a little more than just
hello I'm Jarrett I'm one of the
guardians of this temple over the Kyber
crystals is my friend BAE's hello that
friendship in rogue one is one of my
favorite aspects of this movie I think
it's so well realized between the two of
them you you see like a world they're
like they've been friends for 20 30
years for all we know it really sells
that friendship through their emotion
you feel like these guys have known each
other forever but you don't really know
why there's never anything else
attributed to it beyond the fact that
they're just really cute likable guys
and they kick a lot of ass one thing I
noticed about this movie when compared
to force awakens strangely enough they
both have a very strong female
protagonist that's brunette who has a
scene where they are kicking ass and a
man's about to come up in there and help
and then they just get this shocked look
and they just kind of stop and force
awakens Rey is beaten up dudes and
finish like oh okay I guess not to do
anything the same thing happens in rogue
one Jenny's beaten up dudes and jaga
Luna is like okay I guess I don't have
to do anything it's it's kind of like
really we just did that a year ago
Riz Ahmed who I thought was amazing in
Nightcrawler here plays a pilot
eventually we learned that he was in
some way I guess inspired by Galen or so
to defect from the Empire
we don't really know why he seems to
suggest that he inspired him to know
what he should do inside of him and that
made him want to defect and help people
get that information from Galen to other
people so he tries to go to Sagar era
and we get a very interesting scene
we finally have a Star Wars tentacle
porn scene I've wanted one of these
forever it's I can't even explain how
many letters I have written to Lucasfilm
over the years to get me a hentai
tentacle porn star wars scene
I can't give a straight face city boy um
I don't really get that scene I
understand what's happening uh
Sagar arrow was trying to test if he was
a liar or not so he has this big monster
come in and starts wrapping his
tentacles around the pilot and um it
kind of makes him lose his mind for a
while I guess because when they find him
in the cell he's like uh I'm uh I'm a
pilot I'm the pilot and then it just
goes away I guess it just felt like such
a weird scene like a just such a tacked
on moment that strangely enough we have
a mind-reading tentacle monster
exploring this characters mind and we
still don't learn anything about him so
in my spoiler free review I said there
was a motion capture character that at
times distracted me and that character
is Tarkin now when he's introduced it's
his reflection on a window and he's
looking at the Death Star and there's
someone behind him talking and when he's
just staring out into space I was like
oh my gosh this is amazing holy
this is so perfect I love what they're
doing and then he turns around you get a
full close-up and then he's in the rest
of the movie a lot really big grand
shots of a motion capture Peter Cushing
who no longer is alive and I thought
what they were doing at first was really
respectful just showing him from behind
with that reflection but the fact that
he's in this movie so much to me was the
giant distraction it's not necessarily
bad motion capture work but my best way
to describe how it took me out of the
movie is to actually reiterate what the
guy sitting behind me said when Tarkin
turned around the guy whispered to his
friend oh that CGI
and that's exactly how I felt it just
you instantly zero in on it as not real
it's really good motion capture work but
when we are in a world where you can
look at dawn of the Planet of the Apes
or even the trailer for war for the
Planet of the Apes and just be blown
away by what Andy Serkis and company is
doing this to me felt lacking and
there's another motion capture character
in the very last shot Princess Leia
Carrie Fisher my issue is that when you
fully CGI a human being you better make
it damn near perfect and I'm talking
about perfect even George Lucas when he
made Revenge of the Sith knew to put
grand moff tarkin in just one wide shot
and that was it
they didn't over rely on that granted
the technology wasn't quite up to par
2005 but I just feel like say 20 30
years from now if I popped in Empire
Strikes Back that films still going to
hold up if I pop in rogue one in like 30
or 40 years I have a feeling that I'm
gonna zero in on Tarkin's face and be
like oh my god that's 2016 motion
capture work right there maybe I was
thinking too much into it maybe some
people won't be bugged by it but for me
it just really took me out of every
scene he was in and what I wish they had
done was just have a few scenes with him
maybe do like that reflection in the
window thing and not focus on it too
much and take some of the scenes that
were with him and put Vader in those
scenes so you could have a little more
with Vader because going into this movie
obviously most people are pretty excited
about seeing Vader unless you are one of
those people that followed every little
ounce of internet speculation and
spoilers or maybe you read catalyst
these are all things I haven't done I
just watched the three main trailers and
then saw the film so naturally I was
excited for a little more Vader we do
get a badass scene that scene
oh my god goosebumps everywhere just so
that's what I need I wanted a little
more of that I would have preferred if
Vader was on that beach with the rebels
and the Empire that would have been
amazing if he was more included in that
but that finale is incredible it's such
a great scene although it does feel
almost like a
reshoot scene it does it feels as if
it's been reshot and changed and
according to reports they did change the
ending and there's a lot of things in
the trailer as well that don't show up
in the movie like the TIE fighter coming
up towards Jin on that walkway that's
not in the movie her I rebelled line is
not in the movie which I'm fine with
there's a lot of things Sagara saying if
you continue to fight what will you
become in the trailer he's bald when he
says those lines and in the film the
only times when he's bald is when he
rescues young Jin for the rest of the
movie he has gray hair so I'm not sure
what movie was being made but it has
been heavily altered and if you pay
attention to the way a film is edited
and you're looking for a tone and you're
looking for everything to feel as if it
flows naturally then it's possible that
rogue one is going to feel a little
rocky for you it's first 2x especially
on second viewing drag there isn't all
that much of interest happening for a
while until we finally get the big
incredible third act there are some fun
action sequences like the shootout on
Jetta Donnie Yen kickin ass one of the
things I really liked about rogue one is
how it handled references it wasn't to
beat you over the head
the c-3po and r2d2 shot I feel like was
just sort of so that they could be in
this movie because c-3po and r2d2 are in
every Star Wars movie so I feel like
they're like whoa we got to put them in
this one because they're in everyone
I like the death sentence on 12 systems
guys showing up that was really cool one
of my favorite scenes in this movie that
actually lets a little bit of Jin's wall
down and you can kind of see into her a
little bit is when she receives the
hologram message from her father I
thought that was a really emotional
scene and really well acted on Mads
Mikkelsen sparked and Felicity Jones
also it leads to my favorite part of
rogue one easily the thing I love the
most about this movie which I talked
about in my review as that thing that
helped correct a flaw that people have
talked about with a new hope for a long
time what that is is that it's so easy
to blow up the Death Star I mean it's
not easy easy you call that easy but I
mean technically that's it's a horrible
weakness it wasn't easy for the rebels
to do what they did but it's a terrible
weakness why would the Empire does
well that's because they forced a man to
help them build this who didn't want to
do it so he gave the ultimate middle
finger to the empire by designing this
shaft that gets down to the reactor
that's so great
I mean that adds an entire new layer to
a new hope and that's easily my favorite
thing about rogue one and that's because
it's the one thing that this film does
that helps shape and an add to what
we've already had it builds to the
overarching story of the Star Wars saga
it's the one thing that I can pinpoint
as something that genuinely impacted the
entire Star Wars universe for a better
and Forest Whitaker dies in this scene
pretty early on in the movie
surprisingly because they decide to test
the Death Star on Jetta City and that
thing just blows up and that is
some incredible CGI again I can't
complain about pretty much 99% of the
CGI in this movie is incredible it's
beautiful there are gorgeous action
scenes in this movie that had me
white-knuckled so let's talk about the
introduction to Darth Vader the shot
with the shadow when the door opens and
the shadow is just humongous behind
cranek a thing of beauty
now this scene is a lot of fun because
Darth Vader is in it and James Earl
Jones is in it but easily the best part
of that is when he chokes cranek and he
says don't choke on your aspirations
director and I was like oh my god that's
the Darth Vader line that I'm taking
away from this movie and it's easily
like the Darth Vader line like the rest
of it is him just kind of talking about
you know that's not there's no Death
Star you know the Death Star doesn't
exist that this was a mining accident
and then he has like an amazing moment
and I just wish I got more this guy he's
such a great you know my favorite movie
characters of all time so obviously I
wanted more Vader seeing it a second
time I was prepared for that so I was
able to go in and be like okay I know
I'm not gonna get a lot of Vader but
let's just experience the film anyway
and still leaving I'm like oh I need
more of that guy so Jin is unable to
convince the rebels that these Death
Star plans are there and that they need
to be taken and that it gives them a
strategic advantage so she gets a rebel
band like rebels
of rebels who volunteer to go and get
these plans and eventually I guess the
rest of the Alliance kind of gets
excited about it too and decides well
they're already there fighting let's go
help him and it was kind of like oh okay
why just go in the first place you know
I mean just just go like I get why they
didn't want everyone to go because then
it would seem like there was too much of
an advantage you gotta make it seem like
the heroes are small like they're
vulnerable but then later the rebels
come anyway so it's like just go just
have everybody be like yay let's be a
rebellion and have hope there's a line
in this movie that actually really
touched me for some reason even though I
don't know anything about Bayes when
Bayes looked at her and went good luck
little sister I was like oh that's
adorable
I like that and it just kind of it just
made me smile also something they did I
thought was really cool was they reused
older stock footage from a new hope of
the various fighter pilots that were in
a new hope to include them in this
squadron which I thought was a really
cool idea and my god what a missed
opportunity though we could have had
more Porkins but we didn't get more four
kids that's not really probably just can
you imagine how funny that would be in
fact maybe that's why they did because
it would have been just so amazing like
oh my god poor kids new footage of
Porkins and there's a scene in the
Empire Strikes Back with 80 80s Luke
says that armor is too strong for
blasters rogue group user harpoons and
tow cables go for the legs but in rogue
one the 80 80s are being down by x-wing
fire which I didn't quite get it seems
like perhaps they're hinting that after
this Beach battle maybe they armored up
those 80 80 s for Empire Strikes Back
because it seemed like it was a lot
easier to take down the 80 80s in this
film one of my favorite parts about the
epic space battle which I must reiterate
is really great is the hammerhead the
ship that plows into the Star Destroyer
and shoves it into the other one that
was such a cool idea it's also not a
ship that I knew of existing in the Star
Wars universe so that was really cool to
see and the film tries to retain an
emotional chord of Jin's connection with
her father by the fact that he has named
the Death Star plan file Stardust and
that's how she knows which one it is no
in my spoiler free review I said the
film didn't really surprise me that much
and that's true I went into this movie
thinking that everyone
just gonna die and that that's how it
would end and that's how it ended I mean
there wasn't really anything that I
thought was like oh okay like I I would
have been fine with gin kind of escaping
with Diego Luna or at least attempting
to find a ship I mean they're in like
this incredible giant area with all
these like pilots and ships I'd there's
got to be a ship somewhere they could
have found I just feel like they kind of
gave up because the script wanted all
the characters to die but since I didn't
feel an emotional connection with any of
the characters and since most of them
felt very disappointingly bland to me I
didn't really care I didn't feel that
weight or that impact and I have the
smallest little nitpick that I guess
doesn't really mean anything but to me
it felt like very sloppy editing at the
end when Diego and Felicity Jones are
hugging and the explosion is nearing
them they have their eyes closed and
then at the last second Daigo luna kind
of opens his eyes and looks over like
that and then the explosion encompasses
his face and I was like that was sloppy
like I've never seen that why did he
randomly open his eyes at the last
second to me that felt like rushed
editing there are a few edits in this
film that do feel very rushed there's an
edit where it's coming up towards
critics face when he's sitting like this
on a ship and he looks over and right
before it cuts his eye darts like this
over to the to the right it's a very
sloppy edit and there's there's edits
like that in this movie where it feels
as if they've really been trying to get
the final cut out there as quick as
possible due to all those reasons so
yeah seeing the film a second time
confirmed to me what I felt the first
time I like rogue one I'm excited to buy
it on blu-ray and add it to my Star Wars
collection but it is not a flawless
movie and I have issues with it there
are things that I think they really
could have done better and the reshoots
to me feel apparent I do want more Vader
as I said in my spoiler free review but
I understand that he's not integral to
this specific story but they could have
made him more integral I mean this is
fiction people you know someone said to
me you know Darth Vader's not supposed
to be a part of this story he's not
necessary for this story and I went why
this is fiction you can make up anything
you want it just has to adhere to
certain story beats that relate to
information we learn about in a new hope
other than that
you can do whatever you want you could
have you know Boba Fett just show up
like you could do anything and I would
have liked a little more of him but
still this is a very fun action movie
that for me is emotionally lacking those
are my spoiler filled thoughts on rogue
one a Star Wars story what do you guys
think of the film I understand that a
lot of people enjoy the film from what
I've heard from just tonight's
screenings I understand that some people
are very mixed and a few people actually
hate it but I mean that's to be expected
it's a Star Wars movie the real reaction
for a movie this big isn't really going
to be felt till months from now the
general consensus it's going to take a
while because people are still on this
super high from it I mean I'm still
coming down off of being excited about
it guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to something very
cool very soon I'm traveling to Chicago
to partner up with one of my biggest
YouTube inspirations Doug Walker aka the
nostalgia critic we're going to be
working on a giant epic rogue one review
for him for his channel channel awesome
I can't wait it's going to be so much
fun
you guys are the best and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]